I honestly feel that I should be a
selfie director like you're behind the
camera directing correct I'm in front of
the camera lens directing myself get it
it's like you holding that camera right
there
act shed and then everything cuts back
to you like this and cut hey guys it's
jo koy and these are my essentials first
and foremost I can't live life without
coffee and I can't just be coffee four
shots of espresso with vanilla powder
over pearl ice cubes although we can get
back is the economy what's so good about
the powder have you ever tried to syrup
tastes like crap
powders kind of like the texture to
coffee you want to give your coffee a
little texture throw some powder in it
what why are we this is actually liquid
I collect Rolexes they were like career
goals I think everyone should have goals
it doesn't matter what they hurt
set a goal knock that goal down and they
set another goal that's how you climb
mine is Rolex my 20th year I bought a
solid gold presidential this was your
third solid gold my son this is how he
feels about the Rolexes they're mine
right dad everything that I've
accomplished is all going to hit so
actually I'm wearing my son's Rolex I am
I will spend five paychecks they've got
all the colorways - that's what I love
about this bag it's so subtle but yet
you know it's Gucci they got shoulder
strap then they got the blue and red
here
so I have an ass because I don't like it
when people fly next to me and they
sneeze and then the sneeze goes in my
mouth see without this I'm flying
and then someone actually goes yep and
then I go oh it blew malaria into my
throat
so enjoy your cold this is why I have
that backpack are you kidding me head to
toe I look good and then I compliment my
outfit with this it's called death grey
whoever designed the bag let's make it
him let's put up let's put a hint of
turquoise blue the single this is this
is what I have to carry or else I die so
this end of the hose goes right here and
then you take this part of the hose and
you stick it right here on your Bane
mask are you ready ladies
you know mercy nice oh my god that was
beautiful
it's time for bed I'll see you in the
morning I wish I was exaggerating
without this I can't sleep it shoves air
down my throat
I don't breathe like it's not snoring
people think sleep apnea story no it's
not for so reason my brain is like oh
you're going to sleep Joe and I'm like
yeah and then my brain is like okay us
too so everything shuts the [ __ ] off the
whole body take out for CPAP to be there
kinda like my my favorite sunglasses
these are my goat cheese right here
these are my Vinci's I think you say it
like that Givenchy I don't even know I
like big glasses like huge what I'm
wearing them people are like oh my god
you musta had LASIK do they have to be
that bit get it like here's my ears
I need this part to like be even with
this ear
I like my glasses big like this and it's
hard to find so when I get them I buy
them now you're probably wondering to
yourselves why why do you buy big giant
rings because I have been blessed with a
large head it's a size 7 to 3/8 that's
massive
you have a head that big you should only
have a yellow shirt with a black zigzags
stripe across the chest
that's a charlie barrel reference while
you young kids that don't know who the
[ __ ] Charlie Brown is this is what
happens when you wear smaller glasses I
look like Laurence Fishburne in the
matrix the iPhone why always buy the
newest one they can sell me anything at
Apple and guess what I do I'm [ __ ] by
it everything they say to me I don't
even understand it and then I go like
this I'll take it you have it in black
top three apps on my iPhone are you
ready Instagram iMovie and glow puzzle
hey since you like glow puzzle here's
popcorn hole swipe to start okay
basically it's a hole and you try to
stick as much popcorn in that hole in
seconds
I play the dumbest game
right here is an original piece this is
off-white denim I got this one in Japan
I love this piece right here this one's
beautiful loo that fitted sleeves
tapered on the side you rock this and
people know that it's something special
I love rocking this one and then I
personalize it can I show you from the
ghetto to the Getty
it's exactly what it is man you know I
mean you bust your ass like I said you
try and get those goals and you set
yourself to the highest goal you know
when I first started stand-up I used to
rent theaters you know that worked in
the best areas those are your humble
beginnings and then you know 30 years
later you get to play the Blaisdell
arena in Honolulu Hawaii so it's got a
lot of meaning to it my son's mom her
boyfriend is an artist he designed that
piece right there it's also what I wore
in the special so I'm actually rocking
his piece on stage boom that's how we do
it all I know is Virgil you are killing
the game you know bringing that that
flavor in that culture to the masses is
something very very special and I'm just
happy that this happened during my
generation if I can rock Virgil [ __ ] I
will he's a modern-day genius man I've
been on this kick because I love shorts
I like to wear them year-round I really
did so what I've done now is I wear
spandex underneath my shorts do you want
to see them this is what I like to wear
I wear spandex a lot I do have a little
bit of an insecurity with my leg do we
want to get graphic
you sure when I was 15 I almost died on
a motorcycle compound femur fracture
that's when the bone comes out of your
leg it's also the biggest bone in your
body sticking out about this far my shin
both bones broken tibula and fibula
burnt all the way up for my ankles all
the way up to my knee and my knee was
dislocated
so don't ride a motorcycle that's why I
wear
what the only pair of Nikes he should
everybody this is something that I
rocked on the special as well I was
actually gonna walk out on stage with
some Nike Karachi's some blue standard
haraki's and my son was like nope you
need something special for your stuff
and he's like you need to get them off
like Presley's dad so big shout out to
Virgil again this to me this is this is
artwork
this isn't even a shoe right here it's
the art piece
what do I like about it everything this
is when when you're so creative and you
take every ounce of creativity and you
build it right in front of you I haven't
seen a piece this beautiful
since the Jordan threes there's a real
shoe head right here you guys I was
rocking Jordans when Jordan was playing
so stop don't you ever [ __ ] say that
to me family owned business right here I
put them on the map y'all owe me 808
baby 808 all day every day look at that
all the way from Maui
if you're ever in Maui go the mall there
there's only one don't go which one
there's only one mall there just go to
180 his name of the store is called 180
I I can't get enough these hats man boom
come on
real low don't let him see your eyes man
I love everything about Hawaii I love
the fans there I love the people there
why is it everything to me are you
kidding me that's why I broke the record
I never sold that many tickets in my
life before I saw 24,000 tickets
six months in advance I remember
performing at the Queen couple on e4
handing out free coupons to everybody be
like 400 chairs empty and just six
people it would be the six people I
begged a couple but you know you still
perform like people don't know that
people think that it just always happens
that's not what happened I remember
those six people and that's special to
me I don't carry big giant billfolds
I don't carry cash I only carry one
credit card this is all I carry yes it's
heavy
have you ever heard that I'm gonna buy a
house with it go ahead it goes in here
product what I love the most about Prada
you know it's something when you look at
it whenever I wear a Prada suit I always
get like you know who made that that's
beautiful
every time I wear it it just looks like
a piece and that's what sells the name
and they believe in their product I
don't think anyone's in here I'm Jo koy
and those are my senses